look how cute that duck dynasty star
Sadie Robertson is opening up
exclusively to ET about her new
boyfriend Texas A&M quarterback Trevor
Knight he's a great guy treats me right
super supportive so it's a good
relationship right we've only been
dating for three weeks so it's a new
relationship yeah he had messaged me
because he goes to Haiti every year on a
mission trip and he saw that I go to
Haiti and he was like what are you doing
Haiti so I know telling him and we just
kind of connected through that Trevor's
already met the family and earned the
Robertsons stamp of approval you know my
family's a little scary and a little
intimidating so and they're big LSU fans
and he of course place for Texas A&M so
that was kind of funny but he's a good
guy even football field was nice to have
one just like whoa hi he was like
friendly like he was like he like came
over said hey and I wish him luck on the
season I'm like what is happenin that
was good
while her new beau gears up for football
season Sadie's ready to hit the road on
her live original tour bringing some of
her famous family members along for the
ride
it's gonna be fun but it's also gonna be
really life changing I think people are
gonna feel really inspired and leave
there feeling like they can really make
an impact in the world and change the
world themselves with who they are
are we in Brighton busy wedding planning
oh yeah I mean Brighton was just text me
like we had to plan the bachelorette
party because I'm the maid of honor so
I'm like oh shoot okay what kind of
bachelorette party are you planning well
you know we're kind of like all underage
so it's not probably like most people
graduate party but I think we're gonna
go out to a family camp and get people
to come in and do like massages and
stuff so very relaxing
you